in terms of why I move from law to media
it was a little bit accidental actually
I had always been interested in
journalism I had been involved in
journalism in high school and college
where I worked on the school newspaper
at Harvard at the Harvard Crimson and I
then after a number of legal jobs i
clerked for judge I worked at a law firm
and then I went to the US Attorney's
Office I found myself wanting to get
back into non legal writing and so kind
of on a lark I started a blog
anonymously because i didn't really know
how it would affect my day job I started
a blog called underneath their robes
which was kind of like a people or in US
Weekly but focused on federal judges
oddly enough so that essentially is how
I first made the transition and I was
doing that while balancing my day job as
a prosecutor and then eventually that
blog developed a following and that was
essentially my entry point into media
I'm glad I made the move from from law
to media I still practice a little bit
because the blogging company that my
site above the law is part of breaking
media has me as its in-house counsel so
I still do a little bit of legal
practice but it's really five or ten
percent of my time as opposed to a
hundred percent of it and for me
everyone is different for me I just
enjoy the day-to-day work of being a
blogger more than the day-to-day work of
being a practicing lawyer but everyone's
different some people tell me oh I would
never want your job
in terms of underneath their robes I
think that that blend of law and gossip
reflected two aspects of my personality
on the one hand i can happily sit down
with an issue of the harvard law review
on the other hand i can happily sit down
with Us Weekly so I think it reflected
my own bifurcated personality in a way
these twin interests that I had the
other thought that I had about it was
people love to talk about judges with in
legal circles when they're appearing
before a judge they want to know what
the judges like people also look at
judges a little bit like celebrities of
their legal world these are the people
who are making the big decisions who are
affecting the lives of millions and at
the time that underneath the robes was
started certainly there wasn't a lot of
attention paid to judges as people
people would examine their rulings for
instance or their jurisprudence but they
wouldn't really examine them much as
people one thing I think that has
changed since I started underneath their
robes in 2004 and today is we have been
through three supreme court confirmation
hearings Chief Justice Roberts Justice
Alito and justice Sotomayor and I think
now people are much more attuned to the
personal narratives of judges for better
or worse but at the time that i started
underneath their robes this was a little
bit of a backwater
it's a tough time I think to start blogs
when I first started underneath the
robes in 2004 and then when i launched
above the law in 2006 there were many
fewer blogs than there are now now
everyone and their mother has a blog
every news organization has dozens of
blogs and one of the challenges is to be
heard above the noise and there is
definitely a first mover advantage to so
there are a lot of blogs that people go
to not necessarily because they are in
some abstract sense better than the rest
but because they bookmarked them or
they've put them in their RSS reader and
just by force of habit they they go to
blogs so in terms of when i started
above the law that was in 2006 i had
been working at wonkette the political
blog that was my first full-time
blogging job after I left the US
Attorney's Office and I came up with the
idea for above the law because I thought
there was nothing like a long cat or a
Gawker type site for the law at the time
there were a couple of blogs that
focused on substantive legal
developments like the wall street
journal's law blog which focused on law
and business cases or how appealing
which is a block by Howard bashment
which focused a lot on appellate
developments or SCOTUS blog which
focused on the Supreme Court but there
wasn't a blog out there that offered a
bit of fun and humor about the
profession as well as industry news and
gossip and so I thought that there was
an opening there that there was a need
in the market that wasn't being filled
and so that's when I came up with the
idea for above the law
you